hi i'm lucas from the upcoming peacock
series angeline and i'm here with
buzzfeed to read thirst tweets
first one is lucas gage breathing me
hearts
hearts and hearts
that's really nice thank you lucas gage
is kinda cute should i stand love that
you didn't use any grammar and any like
question mark so
i kind of stay on you yeah lucas gage is
the prettiest man alive you can't change
my mind
that's so nice
yeah
sure thank you i'm looking respectfully
at lucas cage that's kind at least it's
not disrespectfully it's always lucas
gage from euphoria or lucas gage from
white lotus and never lucas gauge from
the hit go 90 series tag so true bestie
brown fans you guys get it you guys are
the real ones unfortunately i am a sim
for lucas gage who could have seen this
coming not me who gave
lucy's gage the right to be
that hot my mother
paulina thank you i fear i shall perish
if lucas gage doesn't make out with me i
like that one that's a good one that's
really good right but can we talk about
a blood tea no actually i want to do it
in the british accent all right can we
talk about how bloody beautiful lucas
cage is as you can tell i'm out here in
london filming a show and my accent
uh petitioned to make lucas gage the
white boy of the month i'll take what i
can get at this point i gotta take
anything
lucas gage can kick my ass and that is
just that i've gotten my ass kicked a
lot i feel like i deserve to kick some
other people's asses in return lucas
gage got a paycheck to get bronzed in
the hawaiian sun kiki with jennifer
coolidge and get his ass ate by murray
bartlett spelled wrong goals i mean it's
not a bad life lucas cage has a really
nice ass though sad crying emoji it's
kind of square
of has sharp corners but thank you very
much i have been doing a bit more squats
lucas gage got his ass eaten and it's
not me who was eating it hate crime
sorry wasn't my decision uh watching the
white lotus isn't enough i need to eat
lucas gage's ass oh my god enough is
enough you guys just woke up from a
dream where i was on a date with lucas
gage not because now
i'm mad i need him don't be mad about it
luke is gay specially
i hate you
but that was pretty funny lucas gage if
you're reading this i want your fingers
and your toes in my mouth right now chop
chop handsome
hot
that was hot i feel violated i feel
loved i feel
seen i feel heard
i feel very lucky to have such thirsty
fans and
so honored that you
love my hat
thank you buzzfeed for having me and
reading my thirsty tweets make sure you
watch angeline on peacock may 19.
[Music]
you